[Music]
the grip this song has on me i love it
that was alesso and zara larson teaming
up for their latest collab words and all
i have to say is sweden is in the house
over here at et welcome hi i'm also
happy to sit with you guys i told you
this song is on heavy rotation and stuck
in my head which is a good thing i think
right amazing right yeah it's great so
yeah yeah um i just can't believe y'all
haven't collabed before how is that
possible how did this one finally come
together well i've always wanted to work
with zara yeah we're thinking about it
for a while yeah and uh we have mutual
friends we bumped into each other
for years you know and i always look for
someone that can really carry dance
records and she has that strong voice
that you need and then we find the right
song and she was on board
[Music]
how was it for you guys to be able to
write and record this in sweden i mean
it's where we live so like it makes
sense yeah um but it was really nice
because i feel like for me at least i'm
kind of off when i'm in sweden you're
like
yeah i'm like oh i'm meeting my friends
and my family um but it's it's always
nice i mean i love what i do so like if
i get to sing a bit in the studio well
this song is amazing i know fans were
excited for you guys to finally team up
too in fact when you teased the lesson
on tick tock that you were going to be
collaborating with somebody they knew it
was you just based on bracelets
they borrowed detectives yeah like
i think fbi should reach out to these
people and get some help i don't know
it's just crazy the fans are hardcore
yeah yeah yeah kind of terrifying
no one's safe
[Applause]
but you're holding the light
[Music]
i want to talk about the video because i
mean you guys really outdid yourselves i
feel like especially from the fashion to
the visuals um talk to me about putting
together the video for for words yeah we
have some few ideas actually and then
was it your idea well we wanted to find
uh an idea that fits both our worlds uh
you know uh look and design and you know
i love a little glamour also we shot on
film
film which is really cool colors are
popping yeah and it was kind of blend
her world with my world and just do
something that looks really cool and
that we both uh love and want to
represent and it has like two worlds of
like
beauty and then there's rave then
there's you know this greek mythology
inspired scenario and yeah just wanted a
sick ass video
[Music]
let's talk about the lyrics though
because it is about following your heart
but i also feel like it's about being
afraid to say i love you because of the
reaction from your partner is that
something you guys can relate to like
talk to me the inspo for this song me
personally i'm like
going one day and i'm like i love you
oh you don't waste any time huh no i'm
like when are we getting married like
what's like when do we get
accountability
i'm exactly the same are you yeah yeah
i'll i'll
do you find that it's too soon or do you
love that you guys are just kind of
lovers and not fighters you know
not fighting i think it's great i think
it's great but i do i can i can relate
like i've been in a situation where it's
like oh like i feel like i like you way
more than maybe you like me
or like
maybe
maybe it's not even true but like in my
head i'm like maybe i should chill like
be the cool girl or like be someone like
oh you know i'm just casual like we just
meet casually or whatever but really i'm
like i really like you i got the words i
love you
but alyssa you recently started a new
residency at tao in las vegas how stoked
are you to be playing this on repeat for
the crowds in sin city and it's the best
yeah and uh i've been really excited
about this song for a while so uh the
fact that we recorded it in was it in
december january and now it's out
already that is like rare you could take
yeah and i love that because then it's
fresh in my ear too you could be sitting
on a record for a year and it's fine but
like when you made something you're like
i want this out first and it worked
perfectly with her schedule as well and
now yeah i just got to bring her to the
back
[Music]
you'll be joining bad bunny on tour like
come on crazy how excited are you to
kind of like i don't know
i of course everyone knows you're a
global superstar but to also be in
someone else's turf for a little bit and
meet their fans yeah it's pretty crazy
the tour is called world's hottest tour
and it feels like it is because it's
stadium tour right now he's the biggest
it's definitely
very exciting and i've known him for a
couple years and we always wanted to do
something together
[Music]
i love it and then you're joining
swedish house mafia in the fall right so
when are you sleeping that's what i
wanted well yeah
i don't know yeah i i looked at the
schedule this morning and it it's
definitely the craziest one so far
what do you have coming up next i've
been such a huge fan of yours for so
long and you've put out some records in
the last couple of years too but what
can we look forward to coming up next so
much yeah yeah so that's why i'm here in
l.a i'm working on my album and it's
coming together really nicely
[Music]
till the day i die how would you
describe this next era of zara larsen is
it something you're experimenting with
or is it gonna be a little classic like
a little it's still very pop but like
on this one i'm really i'm really like
singing there's some like
oh she's giving us the vocals
you know you each have collaborated with
so many artists is there anyone on the
bucket list still like who are you
trying to check off on the list next to
work with oh
yeah you can't say any other djs right
now
any other artist though yeah any other
artists any other artist i would love to
um
make a song with
oh
there's so there's so many there's so
many and i kind of would like someone
who like doesn't really make sense you
know what i mean like
like i love her love her new album so
just beautiful r b vibes you know army
vibes i would love obviously like nicki
minaj
like beyonce
[Music]
i had two great collabs this year with
you and katy perry those were two
milestones for me like i said you guys
voices are just like a blessing for
someone like me especially when it's
dance music it's hard to sing on top of
those records
[Music]
thanks to you we got two songs to add to
our summer playlist so thank you and
thank you guys for being here uh we're
gonna have alesso and zara play us out
here's more of their music video four
words and we'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
instead you put it
[Music]